hey guys i'm ryan right let me check out
the trailer today for the film legend
it's a Tom Hardy film every time a Tom
Hardy film comes out I get like requests
up the wazoo to [ __ ] like do the
trailer for it right away
tool motor yeah please please we go so
free be my twins oh my papa
no way with a loo these are the
Crichton's
Ronald and Reginald that's I don't know
about this story
y'all
look slowly
but yeah but yeah looks so [ __ ] cool
I am so [ __ ] sold on this movie
already like I love Tom Hardy I'll
pretty much watch anything as long as
he's in it he's a great [ __ ] actor
just from the first frame and walking
the eyes kind of dark I was like yeah
I'm probably gonna watch this already
because it looks cool the music they
have over the trailer if they have that
kind of music throughout I love it but
right when I found out they were twins
of this is a true story I don't know the
true story of these gangsters but that
is [ __ ] cool I've seen twin gangsters
through in the city how that is so
intriguing just if you say that like
someone's gonna ask like what's legend
about it's about these twin gangsters
true story that ruled the city how could
you not be intrigued by that oh and it
plays the twins Tom Hardy you know it's
gonna be good the production value looks
awesome
it's stylistically shot I love the way
it looks it's the writer of LA
Confidential and Mystic River those are
such good crime dramas man LA
Confidential one of my all-time favorite
crime dramas and that the writer
director he's done a lot of films that I
like you know he did payback with Mel
Gibson he did conspiracy theory with Mel
Gibson and Julia Roberts I thought was
very underrated I think this guy wrote a
Knight's Tale actually I'm really drawn
to the style of this film like it looks
like it's gonna have great acting
awesome cinematography great production
value if it has that kind of pacing of
the trailer it'll be a really
entertaining film and who knows this
might be another Oscar contender for
tomorrow
hey rating time I cannot wait to see
legend
any of you guys really big thanks for
telling me that trailer was out I had no
idea about this film if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
reel rejects and you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter
where we are trying to get product
placement by getting a Sur amount of
followers makes it that easier to get
I'm trying to get product leisa from car
companies you know specifically a
Lamborghini if I can you know like drive
up in front of my living room with the
Lamborghini and really promote it I you
know what guys just letting you know I
wouldn't mind driving it around for you
to help promote it sacrifice on my part
but I'm willing to do it for you